hello everybody hope they are good you
won't believe what just happened to me I
was I just finished recording the video
and then you know I went to Sony Vegas
to edit and I noticed I didn't record
any audio so I have to record again this
video okay but anyway guys it's fine
um let me tell you what I think okay in
the past days we've been talking about
the year that we're inside this range
okay these are different size your range
lows this is your mid-range okay and
then these two dotted Orange Lines
they're the range Porters okay that you
can see how they are support
and resistance okay so that's what I
think I think that we are in this range
now in the last video we were talking
about the idea that this was a deviation
okay
and I didn't even like how the chart
looked why because first you go uh here
there was a lot of liquidations between
Thirty One Thousand seven hundred and
thirty one thousand eight hundred and
you can see that price you know took
that liquidity and then dumped get back
inside the range go to the one hour time
frame okay
go back inside the range this was the
consolidation on the resistance that I
was talking about then short okay so I
took my short here
uh 31 414 it was okay it's a shooting
short I'm still riding that short I took
some profits now of course because price
dumped quite a lot but I'm still riding
that string short okay
um now
a little tip for you guys how
can you get some Confluence that this
was a false move okay going to the Daily
time frame
okay what do you see here let me tell
you uh I see here
a lot of Wicks here okay so this was a
Zone that the market maker kept kept
pushing price up to okay but I didn't
practice so now with this large screen
candle
you know it got everybody so excited but
the problem that I got here is that it
didn't manage to break through this Zone
okay and if you also check the volume
let me show you look at the volume of
this huge green candle okay that go
everybody excited okay look at this
volume
it's very low it's not enough okay it's
not much I'll tell you okay when you see
a clear resistance and then you see you
know a lately candle what do you want to
see first is this large green candle to
break through this resistance with a lot
with a big spike in volume okay and I'm
telling you a spike
diet higher than this at least okay a
spec may be up to here not to here okay
so that it's another bit of Confluence
to the idea that this was a false move
up that got retraced immediately okay
that was you know this move up this
deviation is pure manipulation okay now
uh go back to the four hour time frame
let me remove this uh volume indicator
um again I'm not a volume Trader but
sometimes they can give you some
Confluence okay to see where the
manipulation is now
you know you've got the deviation at one
of the ends of the range then the most
lucky scenario is that you see a
Breakout
in the other end of the range okay and
that will be to the lows this is what I
think in the bigger picture I think that
if I have to choose between a breakup to
the upside or to the downside I'm gonna
choose to the downside why because you
can see here
um how they've taken the liquidity at
the highs okay that's uh one of the
ideas and also I've been telling you
about this going to the one hour time
frame I'm gonna show you what I see okay
the one I see here the range size are
well many large green candles and Wicks
that can retrace in the middle okay let
me show you latinine candle get free
Trace Latin candle creatures again
a week let's continue a bit more okay
you go here another week gets retraced
clock in here
okay large green candles here gets
retraced that's it in Candle get retrace
let's continue a bit more okay
bloodstream candle Ray Trace large green
candle retrace okay do you keep seeing
that over and over again okay now do you
mind say
you could say the same for the downside
can you really okay let me show you the
examples you got one example here one
example here one here and one here so
you go to the downside four examples
okay but in the range size how many you
got
I don't know how many I haven't counted
them but one two three four five six
seven eight nine examples okay so this
is clearly saying to me that the market
making is building his shorts at the
range highs okay that's what I think let
me remove all of this
okay that's also why I think the if we
see a Breakout
I'm sorry for everybody super excited
here I think the breakout is gonna go to
the downside okay and that's something
that I've been saying since you know
we've been back here okay I was telling
you the idea that price should push up
get Aviation hit or lose liquidations
okay right or consolidate on the
resistance
drop and then the next part of the plan
would be a break after the downside okay
so that is still my plan that's still
what I think guys okay now
let's go and back into the four hour
time frame
where do I think the price you know
could find some support well if I look
at the chart this one here okay is the
song where I think we could find some
support hopefully okay here you go some
resistance that hasn't been tested or
supported yet I think so that's what I
think that you know if we see you know
the breaker that I'm talking about to
the downside then this is a Zone where
you could find some uh support and then
you know you could see a little bounce I
mean also you could see a deviation here
get back inside okay here and then you
could aim for the range loads the same
scenario okay these deviations the
player quite nicely so again if we see
now
a Breakout
below the range lows but they managed to
get back into the range test their
support then I'm telling you I'm logging
here to the mid range okay so that's
another possibility uh but in the bigger
picture you know you might see another
Aviation here
um I don't know or some consideration
here when I push up but in the bigger
picture I think we're gonna break it to
the downside
to be honest uh just to be clear with
you guys now let's go into high block
Capital let's see where the liquidity is
first okay but uh now for the day
Traders no don't let me forget
if we go to the one hour time frame this
is uh
a trade setup that I'm looking for today
but between today and tomorrow because
the market looks quite weak looks quite
slow so I don't even know if it's gonna
play out but this is a trigger that I'm
gonna tell you for a trade setup okay
you can see that we are under the one
hour 50ma here okay we've been tested
multiple times and usually when this
happens okay you're gonna see the little
Trader they're gonna notice this because
the 50ma is quite common
EMA to be honest don't I noticed okay
you know this is the main resistance so
I'm gonna Place more shorts into this
Zone okay because I'm expecting that
price comes low okay so in one of these
attempts
what the market making is gonna do is
well
kissing a notice okay there is qualif
shorts
limit orders placed in the 150 May what
about if I you know push price up
test your support this is where you can
enter along okay and then continue
pushing up so anybody that reads you
know placing a limit order here a short
limit order they're gonna be trapped
they're gonna stop here okay so this is
a long trade setup scenario wait for a
push up you know the retrace then you
can lock here and you can aim you know
for the mid-range again if you manage to
get back inside the above the mid range
sorry you know that's another long to
the range quarter also you have here the
Confluence that there are some liquidity
pools here at the left okay you got one
there here on another one here okay
so I mean biggest reason for price to
push up again okay uh maybe you know
again to the range Highs but why not you
know we could retrace these liquidity
pools first
um but for that again you need to clear
the 150 Ma
tested a support
and then you know
with more confidence because now to be
honest as I've told you it's looking
pretty slow pretty weak so
um I don't think you want to you know
long blindly here do you need to see
some confirmation like this reader is
for example okay uh that's one idea I'm
also gonna go now to hablo Capital I'm
gonna see if high low Capital could
consider what could favor the idea of a
short squeeze to the upside okay because
I think that with the 150ma
we got enough reasons probably to push
up a bit
okay we're in Tableau Capital
liquidation levels and you can see the
delta
12 billion dollars worth of short
liquidations okay
um when we were at 31 000
600 or so the Delta was showing 15
billion dollars worth of long
liquidations and then they reversed okay
now you got a very similar amount you
got 12 instead of 15 okay so yeah there
is quite a lot of liquid to the upside
okay look at the spikes at the right in
this chart okay all the spikes are to
the upside these are basically High
leverage shorts okay you can see them
here
targets that I can see of course uh this
one does the closest Target you go here
let me show you there thirty thousand uh
127 aspect close from here but also you
go here
uh this one
thirty thousand eight hundred okay you
know just put it in that one you would
have a gone I think today
top quarter of the range and also fill
at least one liquidity pool so that
would be a good Target okay to close uh
along if you can't manage you know they
Intrigue with the 50ma retrace okay now
if we go into the liquidation hit map
this is the seven days time frame and
the Sunday update that I posted on
Twitter I was telling you that there is
a lot of liquidity to the downside okay
you can say those yellow bars now
yesterday they hit two liquidations okay
there is still a lot more liquidity to
the downside you can see 29 200. that's
right below the range lows okay so
um the question that I asked myself is
is this enough liquidity you know just
to push price down straight away or is
it possible that we see some more
consolidation like we are saying now
because uh to be honest this is just
consolidation okay just to increase the
liquidity here okay uh that would make
more sense to me
so
uh how do I say this okay
um in the bigger picture
we're gonna go here
we're gonna probably break uh below the
range and take this liquidity
but for short term and with short term I
mean today and tomorrow
it's likely the price consolidates a bit
even also it's quite likely that we see
a shorter squeeze
to stop all the shorts before pushing
price down again okay uh that's what I
think so that's pretty much everything
that I think I'm gonna take you now to
the other book let's check the other
book you can see that we are between two
big liquidity zones okay you go to the
downside 29 500 with 265 Bitcoins in
form of buy limit orders uh stop losses
and liquidations okay uh long
liquidations and then to the upset you
go a smaller amount that is 30 500.
with 183 Bitcoins okay so now you can
see the Price Is Right between these two
zones has to make its mind up to see
what zone is gonna go okay before I
finish the video and say goodbye to you
guys I wanted to say that if you support
the content of course you can give a
like a comment subscribe that's good for
the algorithm so the video shows to
other users in YouTube but also of
course you can register with the
referral Link in the description
immediate okay it's an exchange that
doesn't require kyc unless if you are in
the US uh Canada or Singapore I think I
do get five dollar bonus when you log in
also if you deposit at least a hundred
dollars you're gonna participate in the
next giveaways of the trading course
also
um deposits over two hundred dollars get
10 payback that means like you for
example
uh deposit let's say five hundred
dollars then you're gonna get fifty
dollars back and of course you know if
the if you deposit bigger amounts then
you get bigger rewards okay bigger pay
bigger paid backs all right so anyway
guys thank you so much for watching and
I'll see you soon